[Music]
from Disney film subrand six of seven
comes a movie so expensive it had to be
the fourth biggest hit of all time to
make any money but when it comes to
sequels never bet against James mother
[__] Cameron King of the [__]
world baby
Avatar the way of water
[Music]
remember Avatar one kinda right
something about blue elves having
ponytail sex with a flying dog well it's
back and this time they do it with a
fish horse join up with full-time
delator Jake Sully a man who puts the
Marine in Aquamarine when you disobey
direct orders or dismissed and white
natiri just kind of crying in the
background this time around
they'll move the family to space Florida
a Place full of racial tension even
though the water tribe is like one
crayon over but these soggy locals have
their own kinds of nature magic that let
them heal the sick commune with animals
and somehow managed to keep their dicks
and Blues from showing at all times a
Makatea it means double-sided tape watch
this Blue Man's troop start their lives
over in an obligatory underwater level
and even though some of the kids are
getting feels for teals it turns out
that the ocean Nobby kinda salty their
arms are thin the Tails oh are weak
still the Sully Clan is here to do two
things learn about the gentle customs of
the sea people and get kidnapped and
they're all out of sea customs
[Music]
drop it
stop moving you want your kids back you
come out alone
I got your daughters same deal as before
you know for a guy who keeps saying my
family is my Fortress maybe Jake should
I don't know hire a sitter
I'm tied up again
with Earth Resources Tapped Out James
Cameron must invent a whole new culture
for white actors to appropriate with
Kade Winslet just how Cameron likes her
wedge and Sigourney Weaver who's either
chilling like an unopened jar of pickled
eggs or playing your teenage self Curie
the only one higher than you when you
watch this she's just looking at the sun
huh tagging along is spider a tiny
Tarzan who's lucky he was abandoned on
Pandora because back on Earth he would
just be Ross friend
[Music]
boy living in the shanty dorms together
spider and Kiri must face their daddy
issues his dad is a homicidal maniac her
dad is probably an ancient tree goddess
either way neither one is paying child
support and don't forget Jake's
rebellious son log an outcast Outcast
who bonds with a whale equivalent of a
fedora kid he's Outcast and the
responsible son nateam or wait was long
The Good Son which one is which again
Dad just please
it doesn't help that they all talk like
prank YouTubers from 2013. I got this
bro bro bro dude bro bro bro come on bro
come on bro bro come on hey bro I got
you that was insane cause bro that was
insane cuz bro I'm good go oh sick
somehow quarriage has returned and like
any other Disney character who gets
older dies he's been replaced by a CG
version of himself now he's got a Strike
Team of the bluest meanies money can buy
and the ability to instantly find
whatever he's looking for on an entire
planet you're his aren't you that's
hundreds of islands lots of villages
this is our guy I'll be damned so his
kids with the help of this whale goo
Enthusiast and the most immoral marine
biologist since George Costanza he'll
search for two full hours of screen time
before finally finding what he was
looking for an excuse for James Cameron
to pop a sub and really
[Music]
just incredible restraint to wait that
long before popping a sub but after that
students can help himself
cheese two minutes let's get in there so
if you only see one sci-fi sequel about
saving space whales see this one but
isn't it weird that there's two of them
in an experience that is awe-inspiring
in a 3D IMAX theater looks like a
screensaver on your TV at home and
absolute crap here on YouTube that for
all its flaws kept movie theaters in
business for just a little bit longer
and kept audiences from having to live
in their actual reality for three
precious hours
you're right James you were more right
than you ever could have known
[Music]
story Sally is a family guy I see you
less and less these days in the navi
Sigourney tweener the wrong kid died
rastafarianism Tater took the sea was
angry that day my friends Chief Reeve
Kate Inlet what do we do in the shallows
are you pulling my tail
the tales oh this little
boy
talking at the side of their neck let's
go two minutes people let's go gunship's
inbound Eagle I send you traffic I got
eyes on some guys yeah I hear you Iron
Sky Blue on actual
inbound who's with you
you're fire
I'm coming out Sonic flashbacks
[Music]
and
foreign
Go Fish
oh thank goodness this little guy's here
to tell the massive planetary crust
scooping bulldozer where to go right
over there yep that away
hey you guys
Jane get me off this crazy thing
looks like somebody's on the wrong side
of the river I'll do you one better why
is epic voice over a guy